but first I've been warning for weeks
and weeks to keep an eye on the corona
virus that's spreading from China to
countries around the world my concern
was that I didn't trust what China was
saying about it and some breaking news
to report on the virus tonight the US
military just announced moments ago that
one of its soldiers based in South Korea
did test positive for this new virus the
first u.s. servicemember to be infected
now I'm gonna take you through how all
this unfolded today at roughly noon with
the president out of the country
the CDC began sounding this alarm
disruption to everyday life may be
severe but these are things that people
need to start thinking about now people
are concerned about the situation I
would say rightfully so I'm concerned
about the situation CDC is concerned
about the situation on in India with the
markets the president was in India
obviously in the markets plummeting
because of the corona virus spread all
of that accelerating president Trump
also addressed the threat we're working
with China very much on the virus we
feel that's something and I have to tell
I spoke to President Xi the other day he
is so committed to solving that problem
he is he is working very hard he is very
capable the country is very capable and
it snuck up on him but I think he's
going to do well snuck up on him okay I
don't know what to say about that what
was measured it was diplomatic and he's
on the world stage so we like that but I
sure wouldn't trust China on this issue
at all
for starters we still don't know what
sparked this epidemic and Chinese
censors have also been scrubbing the
Internet of any real information about
what's going on within their own borders
but don't count on the w-h-o for any
help on this they're basically complicit
in my view in what China has been doing
to cover this up do we look at okay the
rest of the world would
access the expertise of China and the
you know they've done this at scale they
know what they're doing and they're
really really good at it and they're
really keen to help if I had Kovan 19 I
want to be treated and in China just
stay in China if it's so fun over there
despite all of this of course the
president and his team do have to
prepare for the possibility of outbreaks
here in the United States it's a virus
viruses travel today his working group
was back in Washington and it got into
the specifics the immediate risk to the
general American public remains low but
as we have warned that has the potential
to change quickly
there is now community transmission in a
number of countries including outside of
Asia that's deeply concerning the usual
and appropriate care for most patients
who develop the novel coronavirus or
kovat 19 would be management at home
through home isolation with use of
health care facilities only as needed
for those who have severe presentations
now watching the media coverage today it
seemed like some of the Trump haters
were actually relishing in this moment a
new Avenue it was a corona virus that's
a new pathway for hitting president
Trump how sick that these people seem
almost happiest when Americans are
hurting and of course our markets are
feeling the pain now the sell-off has
been significant and frankly it could
continue as the infection rate grows
around the world and in the United
States we have supply chain disruptions
none of that should be surprising at
this point but while the
administration's messaging on this has
been lacking it is absolutely disgusting
that Democrats are seeking to use this
complex virus to score cheap political
points after their politically
disastrous impeachment and the fierce
intra-party fighting we want to get into
in just a few moments Democrats needed
to change the subject and fast so like
the corona virus itself Democrats and
move too quickly infect the political
discussion with viral recriminations a
senators from both sides of the aisle
today suggested that the amount of money
that the Trump administration is
requesting to combat this to slow it
down is 2.5 billion dollars that that
that's insufficient there's been so many
cuts that have been proposed to these
various preparedness programs there has
been as we wrote today sort of a
Halloween out of the scientific
community in the Trump administration
since he took office okay
the CDC's budget was more than seven
billion dollars in 2019 if that's not
enough to prepare for a global epidemic
they need to do some serious
housecleaning at CDC plus Trump is
requesting that 2.5 billion you just
heard about to deal with the outbreak
and if the Senate believes we should
have more guess what the Senate can
appropriate more with the House of
Representatives working together but you
could throw facts like that at the left
all day long if none of it would matter
Trump could personally go to China to
find a you know some type of cure or
find out who patient zero was and they'd
still say things like this do you have
any confidence that he won't just
arbitrarily shut down entry from Italy
you know New Yorkers or someone from
Kansas goes to La fronte I mean never
bet the Donald Trump will not do
anything that is outside of the norm if
you're so into American isolationism and
you're thinking it's America first well
there's certain problems where which are
really global it has to be solved by
having all of these countries come
together that doesn't work with it as
sort of saying America first nice job
Andy I'd stick with screwing up the law
okay we need more people to come into
the country who are infected and be
truly globally infected what a buffoon
now does anyone actually think that more
globalism is gonna help this crisis yeah
you want to cooperate for sure but bring
in more people from other countries
don't have any concern about who travels
where is that what they were sitting
over at MSNBC today because I'm really
confused listening to that logic that
goes all over the place now for now the
president needs to ignore the political
hack so we're just firing
for airtime and listen to actual experts
and he's assembled a fan not a
phenomenal team to tackle the
coronavirus now this may end up being a
global epidemic but his first
responsibility is to the American people